اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حواري فرنسا اليوم
ياتيكم من لبنان ضيفنا نائب في البرلمان
ومرشح لمنصب رئاسه الجمهوريه اللبنانيه
الطامحون لهذا المنصب ومريدوه كثيرون لكن
ضيفنا هو الوحيد الذي يجاهر علنا من قلب
مجلس النبي برغبته ان يكون القاتل الجديد
لقصر عبده الرئاسي ولو انه يعلم جيدا ان
كواليس السياسه اللبنانيه تستطيع ان تحرق
اسماءا وان تعلي شان اخرى وهي في بعض
فصولها تستطيع ايضا ان تكون دميه هو الذي
خبر اغتيال والده الرئيس الاسبق رنيم عوض
بعد 17 يوما فقط من انتخابه العام 89
اليوم يعيش فصلا اخر من هذه سياسيه في وقت
يعيش فيه لبنان واحدا من اسوا الازمات
الاقتصاديه في تاريخها النائب ميشال عوض
اهلا وسهلا بك على فرانسليت
النائب همم البرلمان اللبناني اجتمع اربع
مرات على مدى شهرين من اجل انتخاب رئيس
وانت لم تستطع الحصول على العدد الكافي من
الاصوات هل فعلا ما زلت تؤمن انه لديك
فرصه كي تكون فخامه الرئيس المقبل في
لبنان
يعني جواب على هذا الموضوع اولا تنشوف
المشهد بكامله انا حصلت عمليه على دعم
حوالي 44 صوت
ولكن
الشعارات فاذا لتاريخ اليوم ما في ولا اي
مرشح لرئاسه الجمهوريه فعليا او البعض
مرشحين هن اعلنوا انه ما بدهم يكونوا
مرشحين فاذا لا تاريخ اليوم في مرشح واحد
لرئاسه جمهوريه سؤال وانت تروح طيب
المقدمه ليش ترشحت ما بالمنطق اللبناني
الواحد ما بيترشح ينطق تسويات
الداخليه واقليميه بينتظر توافقات
بيلطي وما بيقول بوضوح رايه ابدا انا
اعتبرت انه اول شيء وانا ما عم بفقد ولا
منصب انا عم دافع عن قضيه قضيه قضيه لبنان
قضيه الدوله منها المنطقه نحنا بنعتبر انه
وصلنا لهون لانه الدوله اللبنانيه دوله
مخطوفه الدوله اللبنانيه مخطوفه من سلاح
خارجها ومن مافيات داخلها منها
الاستحق والتاكيد انه لا هذا استحقاق
لبناني منه
قاضي على توافق خاضع لانه مسؤوليتهم قلت
تريد ان توحد المعارضه كي كي تفوز او
تستطيع لكن حتى اللحظه الامور في مكانها
روح مش هالقد ما الذي يتغير
ان اليوم في 70% من المعارضه توحدت او
تلفت حولتيها اليوم عمليه ما بقى في ولا
كتله لمعارضه باكملها
همم رافضه الانتخاب لاني صار في مجموعه من
النواب يعني من كل الكتل المعارضه يا كتل
دعمتني بالكامل يا جزء من هذه الكتل ااا
يعني انا وقت اطرحت موضوع جمع المعارضه
انا عارف تماما في الصعوبات لان هذه
المعارضه معارضه متنوعه جيد من خلفيات
مختلفه ومن صراعات بداخلها حكاد انه يقول
انه معاهده مشتته ولكن انا مقتنع تمام
القناعه اذن هل معارضه ما اجتماعات حول
ترشيح وحول رؤيا ولل رؤيه استرجاع الدوله
واسترجاع الثقه
نتيجه الوحيده هي مزيد من الانهيار هي
تحويل هذه المعارضه الى معارضه مشتته والى
حاله اعتراض او مجرد حاله اعتراض لا تاثير
لها بالحياه السياسيه والى استكمال
الاوضاع في لبنان على كل المستويات كما هي
عليها اليوم الامور واضحه في لبنان همم
بمعنى الان البرلمان عليه ان يتمتع بنصاب
86 نائبا و لكي يفوز اي اسم بمنصب الرئاسه
عليها ان يحصل على 65 سنه انت عليكو خط
احمر تحديدا من حزب الله في لبنان يعني
انا حصلنا فضل الله قال انك مرشح تحدي
ولم يجدي ذلك نفعا هل هناك قنوات اتصال مع
الحزام
الرئاسي
من حقيقه انه نصاب في كل الجلسات او كل
الدورات
لانتخاب الرئيس هو 86
وانطلاقه من هون نروح نشوف مين المرشح
اللي قادر يجيبني صف 86 يعني يعمل شبه
اجماع حوالي من الاساس وساعتها من جيب
مرشح هذا المساء هيؤدي الى المجيء بالمرشح
ضعيف رمادي مكبل
لا لون لا ريحه لا كرار لهم لكنك لا
تستطيع ان تستثني مكونات لبنانيه معارضه
هذا المسار الاول باد تحت شعار رئيس
توافقي الى راي استثواوي لا يغير شيء في
حياه اللبنانيين راح تبقى بها الحاله دوله
مخطوفه لبنانيين عم ينزلوا وعم يموتوا
المسائل الاخر اللي انا عرضته هو جمع
المعارضه شو يعني جمع المؤنثه معناه الفصل
بين مرحلتين بالمعركه المرحله الاولى هي
الاكثريه ال 65 لانه هذه المعارضه
المتنوعه هي بتشكل اكثريه نيابيه وشعبيه
نامن اولا توازن بها الاكثري والشعبيه
ونصنع وفاق حقيقي مد يدنا ونسمع وفاق
حقيقي مع حزب الله ومن حوله ولكن ساعتها
في فرق كبير بين الوفاق والتسويق التسويه
اللي بتجيب رئيس الرمادي لانه
ولا قرار
وبتستكمل هيمنه السلاح والفساد على الدوله
اللبنانيه واستغراضا الانهيار والعزل
للبنان الوفاق ووفاق مثل الاجابه الرئيس
فؤاد شهاب بعد ثوره 58 حول مشروع سيادي
اصلاحي ذكر سيد ميسي اجتماع الخيمه على
الحدود مع الرئيس عبد الناصر لتاكيد
السياده اللبنانيه ودوله المؤسسات او
الوفاق اللي بعد اتفاق الطائف انتج الرئيس
الشهيد راني معوض الوالد واللي ادى
اغتياله او اختياله برهان على انه كان
حامل مشروع حقيقي سياده واصلاحي فاذا ان
احنا نعرض على حزب الله مشروع وفاق حقيقي
حول العوده الى الدوله حول اعاده ربط
لبنان الدول العربيه
انا جاهز للحوار مع كل الاطراف ولكن
البدايه هو بجمعه المعارضه
تفويض المعارضه لا اللي تقدر حاول على
الاسس او على الطرحه المشترك للمعارضه
يعني اولا عزل يعني وضع حد لعزل لبنان
واعاده مصالحته مع العالم العربي مع
العالم اثنين
استعاده السياده الدولي معناه التقسيم
الحدود معناتها استرجاع القاره استراتيجي
والسلاح تحت امره الدوله
العوده الى الدستور الى الطائف والى
مؤسسات الدوله استقلاليه القضاء اللا
مركزيه استقلاليه الاداره اربعه الاصلاحات
الاقتصاديه والماليه والنقديه والاجتماعيه
لاكثر عداله بين اللبنانيين فاذا عهد
الاسس انا مني مع قنوات سريه انا ما عم
بفقد ولا منصب انا مع حوار جدي
حاول بالعوده الى العوده الجميع الى منطق
الدوله انا رافض
الاصطفافات الحزبيه الضيقه ولكن انا بدعي
الجميع تنستقلنا تحت سقف الدوله اللبنانيه
تحت سقف سياده الدولتين استرجع اولا
الدوله
بحاله انحلال وثانيا الثقه بلبنان والامل
للبنين
تحدث عن الرئيس الاسبق فؤاد شهاب وارى
صورته هنا حاضره الرئيس الاسد كان ايضا
الجيش قبل ان يصبح الرئيس الجمهوريه هذا
يحلني الى الاسماء التي تطرح الان في
لبنان قائد الجيش الحالي
في حال اصبح هناك توافق حول هل يمكن ان
تنسحب لصالحه اول شيء انا عندي احترام
يعني كبير لقائد الجيش همم جزء عم لانه
اثبت بممارسه للقياده الجيش انه رجع عمل
من الجيش مؤسس فعليه وننظفها من كثير من
الفساد اللي كان مستشفي بهذه المؤسسات هلا
انا قلته بدي ارجع اقول اكيد اذا في توافق
عن يعني لكل حادث حديث واحد اثنين هنتعاطى
باجابه ولكن انا شخصيا لاسباب مبدئيه لن
اثري بتعديل الدستور على ايام
كانت مختلفه بتصور انه في دهوها اليوم
تنعطي فرصه حقيقيه
لقدره مرشح مدني وانا مش عم اقول انا او
لا احد ولكن مرشح مدني انه يوصل الى سده
الرئاسه لانه انا عم بصير هو الترجمه يعني
او ترشيد لازمه قائمه من من التسعينات
لليوم شوفي عدد قاده الجيش اللي وصلوا الى
سدد الرئاسه من قياده الجيش الى سدده
الرئاسه وهذه مش بظهوره ظاهره صحيه
من هذا السباق
ما قلت هذا الكلام قلت لكل حادث حديث بدنا
نشوف الاسس ولكن انا عم اخذ معركه جديه
لاسترجاع الدولي للوصول الى مرشح مدني
سيادي اصلاحي ولكن اكيد انا قابل للنقاش
مع التطورات برجع اقول مش على اساس هيك
وفاكر ماده ولكن على اسس
واضحه
يعني لوفاه وطني حقيقي حول العوده الى
الدوله اللبنانيه
قلب معمل انتاج الرئاسه اللبنانيه الان
فقط تعبير ما هي الخطوط
الاكثر حضورا اتحدث عن الخطوط العربيه
والغربيه حاليا
تعرفين انا شخصيه
معروف وبفتخر بان قدرت في مسيره السياسيه
طور مجموعه من العلاقات العربيه والدوليه
وهذه العلاقات دائما انا وظفت لصالح لبنان
لصالح التنميه في لبنان في لبنان لصالح
السياده اللبنانيه والمشروع الدوله
اللبنانيه مشكله
ولكن انا تكون وانا بعتبر انه في ضروره
وجزء اساس من طرح ومن رؤيه للرئاسه هي وضع
حد لعزله لبنان اللي صار باخر اولاويات
معظم الدول في العالم تعبا من لبنان صراحه
فاذا بدنا نضع حد للعسل نرجع عن صالح
لبنان مع محيط العربي لانه هذا شرط من
شروط الاستقرار وشرط من شروط اعاده النمو
والاستثمار والثقه على على المالتين
الخطوط السعوديه
انام
ترشحت للابنا الاستحقاق
بعرف انه في كثير تحاليل انه تسويه
اقليميه غير ناضجه وبعد التسويه الدوليه
غير ناضجه انا بدي اتوجه لزملائي
نحن عم ننتخب رئيس جمهوريه لبنان منا
ناطرين ولا تسويه اقليميه ولا تسويات
عربيه
وساعه ننتج رئيس جمهوريه لبنان واكيد انا
عم اقول على راس السطح انه من اذن انا
انتخبت من اولى الامور اللي بدي اقوم فيها
هي اعاده
يعني علاقات لبنان العربي والدوليه لو من
دونه ما في لبنان شكرا جزيلا لك النائب
والمرشح المنصب الرئاسه في لبنان
شكرا لكم على المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]